allez je vous propose que nous
commençons d'abord pour rappeler que
c'est je sais que certains s'étonnent
qui est des auditions en même temps que
les examens des des textes des PPL dans
l'hémicycle mais vous savez que cette
période de l'année en octobre-novembre
c'est extrêmement compliqué d'arriver à
placer toutes les auditions entre nos
les auditions que vous menez enfin les
rapporteurs et les le travail en
commission et puis par ailleurs les
auditions qui sont absolument
indispensables des ministres pour
présenter les le projet de loi de
finances et vous savez que nous ne
pouvons pas auditionner les ministres le
mercredi matin créneau réservé pour les
commissions tout simplement parce que le
ministre sont en conseil des ministres
au même moment donc on est obligé de
trouver des d'autres
créneaux dans la semaine le mardi
mercredi jeudi et ça tombe c'est vrai
souvent sur le mercredi après les QG
puisque les ministres étant présent au
QG
c'est évidemment plus simple pour les
uns et les autres du coup de d'enchaîner
mais je sais qu'à certains moments ça
tombe
avec des des propositions de loi
auxquelles vous aimeriez participer en
tout cas au débat dans l'émission je
suis désolé je suis c'est évidemment une
situation
qu'on regrette tous mais il y a pas de
solution évidentes pour
trouver suffisamment de créneaux pour
que nous passions toutes les auditions
que nous souhaitons voilà sans plus
tarder on va commencer et nous sommes
heureux d'accueillir
[Musique]
supérieur et de la recherche pour sa
deuxième audition puisque nous avions
entendu une première fois le 18 juillet
de mémoire c'était votre
durant laquelle audition durant laquelle
vous nous aviez présenté un peu votre
feuille de route et aujourd'hui nous
allons plus spécifiquement vous entendre
sur les crédits de votre ministère dans
le cadre du projet de loi de finance
pour 2023 ceci progresse de un milliard
sans par rapport à 2022 cette
augmentation est efficée sur trois axes
prioritaires à savoir la poursuite du
déploiement de la loi de programmation
de la recherche qui rentre dans sa
troisième année d'exécution le
renforcement des moyens attribués aux
établissements du supérieur notamment
pour compenser la hausse du point
d'indice des fonctionnaires et puis
différentes mesures de en faveur de la
réussite des étudiants et de
l'amélioration de leurs conditions de
vie bien sûr mesure que vous nous
détaillerez je n'en doute pas dans un
instant
évidemment nous pouvons nous satisfaire
de cette hausse du budget néanmoins
évidemment
il reste quelques questions en suspens
et une principalement sur lequel je ne
doute pas nous rapporteurs reviendront
dans un instant la question du
financement du surcoût lié à l'inflation
et en particulier d'augmentation du coût
de l'énergie les opérateurs de
l'enseignement supérieur estiment que
l'envoler des prix de l'énergie
entraînerait alors en 2022 je crois que
c'est plus de 100 millions et en 2023 au
mieux un doublement où on pire un
triplement voir un quadruplement des
coûts or le PLF en tout cas à ce stade
ne prévoit aucune forme de compensation
face à cette situation d'exception dans
les établissements d'enseignant
supérieur que les organismes de
recherche se disent prêts à prendre leur
part de l'effort national mais insiste
aussi sur leur marge de manœuvre
relative et sur le fait que l'accueil
des étudiants et la continuité des
activités de recherche ne serait être
des variables d'ajustement nous sommes
donc évidemment soucieux de vous
entendre sur ce point après votre
intervention liminaire je vous
proposerai de répondre aux questions de
nos deux rapporteurs
Stéphane piouard pour les crédits de
l'enseignement supérieur et leur darkos
pour ceux de la recherche en plus tarder
madame la ministre je vous cède la
parole et je précise que nous sommes en
direct sur le site internet du Sénat
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et les
sénateurs d'abord je peux je voudrais
vous dire combien je suis heureuse de
revenir devant vous pour cette deuxième
audition avec le budget mais qui fait le
lien bien évidemment avec la première
audition donc comme il est d'usage je
vais donc vous présenter ce budget 2023
pour le ministère de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la Recherche et je vais
le faire dans des grandes lignes pour
laisser du temps d'échanges
effectivement aux questions que vous
souhaiterez me poser sans rentrer dans
le détail de la présentation comme vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président ce
budget montre une progresse de près de
1,1 milliard d'euros par rapport au
budget 2022 ceci hors financement
issus du programme d'investissement
d'avenir et de France 2030 il s'agit du
budget du ministère il s'agit d'un
budget qui est en constante augmentation
depuis 2017 je voudrais rappeler que ce
budget depuis 2017 a augmenté de 3,6
milliards d'euros et donc dans cette
optique d'augmentation cette année
je voudrais pour démarrer insister sur
cette augmentation qui est d'autant plus
notable que comme vous le savez tous
elle s'inscrit dans un contexte
économique et je dirais géopolitique
aussi très compliqué que le gouvernement
a engagé des dépenses massives en
particulier et ça a été la priorité
notre priorité en faveur des mesures de
pouvoir d'achat pour les Français et
ceci nous allons vraiment mon discours
va se mettre dans ce contexte
particulier de problématiques et de
mesure économiques et géopolitiques très
forte les crédits qui sont alloués au
ministère je vous le rappelle sont de
25,7 milliards d'euros donc je vais les
qui sont répartis suivant trois
programmes qui relèvent de ma
responsabilité au niveau du ministère le
premier programme que l'on appelle le
programme 150 qui est celui sur les
formations supérieures et recherche
universitaire et de 14,8 milliards
d'euros le second que l'on appelle
programme 172 sur les recherches
scientifiques et technologiques
pluridisciplinaires et de 7,8 milliards
d'euros enfin le troisième le programme
231 sur la vie étudiante de 3,1
milliards d'euros l'augmentation de ces
crédits ministères poursuit vous l'avez
dit monsieur le Président je vous en
remercie donc je vais aller vite
effectivement trois objectifs principaux
et je vais les détailler je reviendrai
tout d'abord sur la compensation du
point d'indice pour l'ensemble des
établissements ce point d'indice c'est
une compensation de 500 millions d'euros
sur ce budget et pour moi c'était
vraiment une ligne rouge et un point
important de ce budget 2023 pour le
futur de nos établissements puisqu'il
est budgétaire c'est-à-dire socle et
pour les établissements
ensuite c'est un engagement que j'avais
pris devant vous devant l'été avant
l'été c'est de préserver la trajectoire
de la loi programmation recherche la LPR
et donc dans ce budget ce sont 400
millions d'euros supplémentaires ce qui
y était prévu pour 2023 qui sont
notifiés dans ce budget enfin financer
un ensemble vous l'avez dit de mesures
nouvelles en faveur en particulier de la
réussite des étudiants et de
l'amélioration de leurs conditions de
vie étudiantes et ceci représente une
enveloppe d'environ 200 millions d'euros
de mesures nouvelles ou de reconduction
pour l'année universitaire 2022-2023
alors dans un premier temps je propose
de détailler un peu en grande ligne les
mesures de la LPR donc comme je le
disais ce sont des trajectoires en
crédit et en emploi prévu par la LPR qui
auront été respecté dans ce budget 2023
ce sont donc 400 millions d'euros mais
dont 350 pour le programme du ministère
puisque 50 millions d'euros de la LPR
étant sur l'espace sur un autre
programme
premièrement une hausse de 143 millions
d'euros pour les universités
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
c'est-à-dire au niveau du programme 150
une hausse de 206 millions d'euros sur
le programme 172 donc ça c'est la grosse
répartition des 350 millions
sur ces 350 millions je voudrais
insister en premier lieu sur les mesures
RH ressources humaines ce sont 114
millions d'euros supplémentaires qui
sont destinés à améliorer la
rémunération et les carrières de
l'ensemble des personnels de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
ces revalorisations et c'est
requalifications d'emplois concerne
l'ensemble des agents qu'ils soient
fonctionnaires ou contractuels qu'ils
soient sous statut de droit public ou
privé et travaillant dans des organismes
de recherche dans des universités ou
école c'est important de le souligner
ces mesures s'ajoutent aux mesures du
point d'indice qui sont compensés par
ailleurs donc c'est vraiment important
puisque la hausse du point d'indice n'a
pas été pour ainsi dire écrasé par les
revalorisations salariales qui ont été
prévues par la LPR mais qui sont bien
additionnelles
on peut ajouter à cette enveloppe RH une
mesure forte une hausse d'environ 40
millions d'euros qui est prévu pour le
recrutement de nouveaux doctorants mais
aussi la revalorisation de leur
rémunération c'est doctorants plus
nombreux et mieux rémunéré c'était
l'objectif c'était un des objectifs
forts de la LPR que nous mettons en
œuvre aussi en 2023 je voudrais à cet
égard
signaler un point nouveau et en plus de
la LPR ce point nouveau c'est ma volonté
que c'est revalorisations qui
s'appliquait jusque là uniquement au
flux de doctorants c'est-à-dire ceux qui
arrivaient les nouveaux doctorants à
partir de janvier du 1er janvier 2023 il
s'appliquera à Lançon des doctorants
c'est à dire au stock des doctorants
puisqu'il pouvait avoir la situation
actuelle un sentiment d'iniquité au
niveau de l'ensemble des doctorants donc
ça c'est une mesure complémentaire qui
sera appliquée le décret devrait sortir
incessamment sous peu en janvier le
deuxième point en plus sur les
doctorants c'est que nous avions un flux
cette année à 1975 euros pour septembre
2022 le nouvel entrée nous leur avons
appliqué en plus aussi les 3,5%
d'inflation et donc nous avons un
salaire brut pour tous les doctorants de
2044 euros cette année tous les
doctorants à partir du 1er janvier 2023
donc un arrêté je viens d'écrire mais je
me trompe toujours excusez-moi un arrêté
ministériel viendra donc très vite
prochainement
valider et mettre en oeuvre cette
ajustement je mets ajustement entre
guillemets qui me semblait une mesure
importante pour nos jeunes doctorants
dans nos laboratoires
en deuxième lieu les autorisations
d'engagement de l'ANR de l'Agence
nationale de la recherche cette année
ils sont stabilisés tels que l'avait
prévu la LPR à 400 millions d'euros par
rapport au point de référence qui était
2020 mais là LPR
les effets visibles de cette
augmentation c'est l'augmentation de
taux de sélection de projet qui est à
23% actuellement je vous rappelle qu'il
était descendu en dessous de 10% il n'y
a pas si longtemps et en crédit de
paiement cette année cela donne lieu à
une montée en charge de projet
sélectionnés avec une hausse d'environ
plus 44 millions d'euros lié à la NR
pris par les mesures précédentes mais
qui est une hausse de cette année
en troisième lieu 91 millions d'euros
permettent de rehausser les budgets des
organismes de recherche et des
universités afin de garantir la
soutenabilité de leur recrutement et
d'augmenter aussi la dotation de base
d'élaboratoires donc c'est une mesure
directe aux établissements qu'ils
pourront utiliser directement pour la
recherche en laboratoire et pour les
rémunérations de certains recrutements
en quatrième lieu d'autres augmentations
pour un montant de 81 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour améliorer les
équipements scientifiques les grands
équipements scientifiques et renforcer
le lien science et société en amplifiant
la diffusion de la culture scientifique
ainsi que les transferts de résultats de
la recherche vers le monde de
l'entreprise il y a les Carnaux il y a
tous les les mesures de labellisation
sciences et société accompagnée de
financement
enfin pour résumer dans l'ensemble de
ces mesures avant de finir le parti LPR
je voulais insister sur la création pour
2023 de 650 postes créés dans le cadre
de la LPF qui viendront soutenir
l'attractivité de la recherche dans ces
650 postes vous avez 160 postes
nouvelles chair de professeurs junior et
377 nouveaux contrat de doctorants dont
on a parlé tout à l'heure ainsi que
94 postes nouveaux pour les organismes
et les établissements mais
particulièrement les organismes
vous le voyez donc le budget 2023
traduit cet engagement d'investir dans
la recherche en poursuivant et en
protégeant cette dynamique de l'APL
mon deuxième point consistera à vous
présenter l'augmentation de 700 millions
d'euros des moyens de l'enseignement
supérieur qui permettra d'améliorer la
réussite des étudiants et de renforcer
une visibilité pluriannuelle des
universités sur leur moyen c'est un
premier pas sur ce sur ce point qui me
tient particulièrement à cœur je
voudrais distinguer trois blocs de
mesure le premier je n'y reviens pas il
est je vous l'ai déjà donné mais c'est
les 143 millions d'euros de la LPF qui
rentre dans ce bloc de 700 millions le
deuxième bloc de 364 millions c'est la
compensation du point d'indice dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure qui rentre aussi
dans ces 700 millions et le auquel on a
rajouté quand même 9 millions de crédit
de titres de notamment pour les
établissements qui n'ont pas les
compétences élargies donc nous avons
rajouté une rallonge de 9 millions
un troisième bloc que je vais un peu
plus détailler c'est environ 160
millions de mesures nouvelles en faveur
de l'enseignement supérieur dans ces 160
millions concernent principalement
premièrement la prise en compte de
l'évolution de la démographie étudiante
nous avions pour l'accompagner mis 50
millions ouverts 50 millions de crédit
mais au titre du plan de relance donc
non pérenne pour les établissements nous
avons donc pérennisé dans le budget
c'est 50 millions précédemment ouverts
au titre du clan de relance pour la
création de place en Master et en
licence qui sont aujourd'hui soclés dans
les budgets des établissements et nous
avons rajouté pour cette nouvelle
démocratie 8 millions pour maintenir à
la rentrée 2023 le taux d'encadrement
sur les établissements relevant du
programme 150 par rapport à
l'augmentation prévue d'environ 6000
étudiants nous avons calculé
ce taux
deuxièmement le financement d'annonce ou
de réforme déjà engagées avec 13
millions d'euros pour les surcoûts
d'accueil des stagiaires dans les
inspects qui sont aussi en complément
d'une somme qui est apportée aussi par
l'Éducation nationale ainsi que 8
millions d'euros pour la création de
place dans les formations en santé pour
la rentrée 2023 2024 8 millions d'euros
qui donc couvre donc les 4 mois de la
rentrée 2023 2024 sur ces formations en
santé je peux notamment vous citer la
création de six nouveaux UFR
d'audontologie la hausse du taux
d'encadrement en deuxième cycle et la
création d'un nouveau site aux Antilles
ensuite la conclusion de nouveau
contrats d'objectifs et de moyens et de
performance avec nos établissements
d'enseignements supérieurs dont je vous
avais parlé lors de ma précédente
audition cela vise à renforcer une
visibilité pluriannuelle des universités
sur leurs moyens mais aussi leur
implication pour la mise en oeuvre de
politique publique prioritaire
35 millions d'euros leur sont dédiés en
nouveau dans ce PLF 23 qui viennent
s'ajouter à l'enveloppe du dialogue
stratégique de gestion qui avait lieu
déjà précédemment c'était l'une de mes
priorités et nous pourrons dès cette
année démarrer cette mise en œuvre et
commencer à voir comment nous la mettons
en oeuvre globalement avec l'ensemble
des acteurs
la programmation immobilière du
ministère avec 30 millions d'euros
supplémentaires en crédit de paiement
mais aussi une augmentation de près de
400 millions d'euros d'autorisation
d'engagement notamment pour permettre le
lancement du campus hospitalo
universitaire Saint-Ouen Grand Paris
Nord
enfin la compensation en base aux
établissements de mesure RH transversale
mise en œuvre en 2022 pour 17 millions
d'euros tels que les revalorisations de
certains personnels administratifs
sociaux et de santé
le troisième partie concerne le budget
qui permet de d'améliorer les conditions
de vie étudiante et de continuer à
lutter contre la précarité étudiante
donc le programme 231 c'est le PLF 2023
et bien sûr la traduction budgétaire des
mesures que nous avions annoncé avant
l'été sur le pouvoir d'achat des
étudiants je n'en citerai que deux
principales qui a un impact sur le
budget PLF 2023 et qui sont un impact de
135 millions d'euros sur ces mesures
d'urgence que nous avons prise le
premier c'est la revalorisation des
bourses de 4% des bourses sur critères
sociaux à la rentrée universitaire 2022
et qui aura un coût en année pleine 2023
de 85 millions d'euros
la seconde c'est le maintien du repas à
1 euro dans les restaurants
universitaires pour les étudiants
boursiers mais aussi tous les étudiants
qui s'adressent aux CROUS et qui
pourraient avoir accès et un manque à
gagner pour les CROUS de 50 millions
d'euros qui leur sera entièrement
compensé par l'État
le PLF pour 2023 permet aussi de
renforcer l'accompagnement des étudiants
de mieux protéger leur santé et de mieux
prendre en compte leurs difficultés je
vais vous montrer quelques vous décrire
quelques mesures je pense au doublement
des moyens consacrés pour lutter contre
les violences sexuelles et sexistes dans
les établissements d'enseignement nous
avons doublé avec plus 1,8 millions
d'euros et c'est pour moi un sujet
important un sujet majeur sur lequel
j'ai eu l'occasion de m'exprimer il y a
deux semaines à l'occasion d'une de la
de du lancement d'une campagne de
sensibilisation sur le consentement nous
amplifierons ainsi notre soutien d'une
part aux associations et d'autre part
aux établissements dans leurs projets de
prévention et de formation
le deuxième point est le doublement des
moyens dédiés à l'accompagnement des
étudiants en situation de handicap soit
une hausse de plus 7,5 millions d'euros
conformément aux conclusions du comité
interministérielle au handicap de
février 2022
le troisième point et la réforme des
services de santé étudiants que j'ai
annoncé la semaine dernière et pour
laquelle je mobiliserai une enveloppe de
8,2 millions d'euros une enveloppe
pérenne pour les établissements les
crédits ouverts l'an dernier pour
financer la distribution gratuite de
protection périodique dans les
restaurants et les résidences
universitaires sont aussi pérennisées
dans les budgets
je pense enfin à l'augmentation de 3
millions d'euros de l'enveloppe dédiée à
la mobilité étudiante pour faciliter à
la fois les études à l'étranger à
l'international mais aussi dans les
changements d'Académie pour les
étudiants qui doivent avoir une mobilité
nationale
le PLF 2023 traduit donc le soutien
apporté aussi au réseau des œuvres
universitaires et scolaires et je
voudrais faire un point particulier sur
ces CROUS et le knos avec le
renforcement des services sociaux des
CROUS puisque nous créons en 2023 40
postes de pérennes de travailleurs
sociaux supplémentaires qui seront
recrutés le dispositif aussi de référent
étudiant en résidence universitaire et
pérennisé afin en particulier de lutter
contre l'isolement des étudiants et
améliorer leur accueil dans les
résidences universitaires
nous avons aussi ajouté 4 millions
d'euros supplémentaires qui seront
alloués à la mise en oeuvre des
objectifs de la loi et Gallim en faveur
d'une alimentation équilibrée de qualité
sachant que ces objectifs impliquent
aussi un renchérissement des coûts
d'approvisionnement enfin en plus de la
compensation du point d'indice qui
correspond pour le programme de 131 à 15
millions d'euros le PLF 2023 permet
aussi la revalorisation salariale des
agents du réseau et notamment je pense
au personnel ouvrier pour 12 millions
d'euros supplémentaires aussi sautés
dans leur dans leur budget
avant de conclure et monsieur le
Président merci de l'avoir mentionné je
voudrais bien sûr rappeler que au budget
du ministère et je reviendrai sur
l'énergie juste après s'ajoute les
crédits de France 2030 c'est un plan
d'investissement massif articulé de
autour de grands objectifs pour faire
émerger des solutions de demain répondre
à ses défis qui nous attendent et qui
attendent nos jeunes en particulier
celui de la transition écologique la
recherche et l'innovation sont
effectivement à la source de nouvelles
découvertes qu'il s'agisse de fonds
marins ou d'espace de nouveaux
médicaments ou de nucléaires
d'agriculture ou de mobilité propre le
déploiement de ces innovations
nécessitera de former de nouveaux
talents en s'appuyant entre autres sur
l'excellence de nos sites universitaires
et écoles ainsi ce sont plus de 13
milliards d'euros qui seront investis au
bénéfice des acteurs de la recherche et
de l'enseignement supérieur et de l'in
sur la période 2020 2027 et nous
accompagnerons les établissements pour
l'obtention de ces crédits au niveau de
des plans d'investissement d'avenir pour
terminer mon propos monsieur le
Président un mot sur la question de
l'énergie effectivement je voudrais tout
d'abord dire que je suis pleinement
consciente de l'impact des surcours mais
aussi des incertitudes qui génèrent pour
nos établissements notamment pour la
préparation des budgets 2023 une
inquiétude et une anxiété pour donner
quelques ordres de grandeur vous l'avez
donné je voudrais les redonner de façon
vraiment sur les deux années selon des
estimations et des modèles qui sont bien
sûr nécessairement incertains mais qui
sont basés sur des données connues à ce
jour les surcoûts pourraient atteindre
alors pour les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur environ 100
millions d'euros en 2022 et environ 500
millions d'euros en 2023 par rapport à
pour les organismes de recherche il
pourrait être de l'ordre de 40 millions
d'euros en 2022 et 200 millions en 2023
par rapport à 2021 en raison de la
difficulté à évaluer avec précision à ce
stade les surcoûts qui seront réellement
subis par les établissements en 2023
nous sommes avec Gabriel Attal en train
de travailler sur un dispositif de
compensation financière pour accompagner
nos opérateurs en étudiant différentes
options et différents scénarios nous
serons en mesure de vous le détailler et
de vous donner les chiffres très très
prochainement
203 qui est quand même la préoccupation
immédiate de nos opérateurs en plus de
pouvoir leur donner des consignes
chiffrées de compensation bien tôt je
réitère des consignes très claires que
j'ai déjà dites et que j'ai déjà
transmises à tous les opérateurs les
contraintes budgétaires liées au coût de
l'énergie ne doivent pas pénaliser ni
les projets de recherche ou
d'investissement ni les campagnes de
recrutement sur les postes ni les
conditions d'enseignement pour nos
étudiants
si cela doit conduire à élaborer un
budget initial en déficit je l'assume
pleinement beaucoup d'établissements
disposent de réserves financières qui
sont la précisément pour faire face
aussi à ces situations exceptionnelles
que nous vivons aujourd'hui et qui doit
quand elles existent être mobilisés
quand c'est possible et quand cela ne
pénalise pas les pointes que je viens de
citer toutefois il faut être clair les
situations d'un établissement à l'autre
sont hétérogènes ces réserves sont pour
une très large part gage et sur des
dépenses futures d'investissement que
nous ne voulons pas pénaliser sur des
projets de recherche à NR ou paysa sur
des provisions pour risques ou encore
sur des remboursements d'emprunt ou des
projets immobiliers pour la transition
énergétique et thermique par exemple
c'est pour cette raison que le
dispositif de compensation nous
permettra d'intervenir afin de
contribuer à l'équilibrage des comptes
lorsque les surcoûts seront
définitivement connus et pour ne pas
mettre aux établissements en difficulté
par rapport à leur projet et aussi par
rapport aux années à venir nous allons
donc les accompagner au cas par cas avec
des mesures quantifiées et des mesures
notes sur le budget qui leur permettra
très rapidement voilà je vous remercie
monsieur le Président merci madame la
ministre pour
cette présentation des crédits
concernant votre ministère sans plus
tard des choses donnent la parole à nos
deux rapporteurs pour la commission lors
d'Arcos et Stéphane piennois c'est l'or
qui commence oui parce que Stéphane et
est très galant donc il me laisse passer
en premier Mathilde dit
je vais reprendre sur
sur la crise énergétique même si du coup
je pense que c'est encore trop tôt dans
la dans l'heure de notre audition pour
vous donner peut-être plus de réponses
bon tous les organismes de recherche que
que j'ai auditionné m'ont dit avoir été
pris à la gorge ça c'est sûr pas le
enchères des prix d'énergie et ne pas
savoir comment boucler leur budget 2023
n'oublions pas que la consommation
énergétique des activités de recherche
comprend une part incompressible qui
peut aller de 60 à 70% par exemple la
ventilation nucléaire on en a parlé le
CEA étant plus impacté alors donc vous
dites que
vous confirmez votre volonté de recourir
à la compensation est-ce que vous
procéderez quand même aussi au cas par
cas en fonction de la situation de
chaque organisme n'est-il pas
envisageable de permettre aux organismes
de recherche bénéficier d'une part des
recettes de la future contribution
temporaire de solidarité au motif qu'il
participe à l'avenir de la nation
notamment sur le plan de la transition
énergétique
concernant le déploiement de la LPR
j'étais alerté sur le démarrage
relativement long des chair de
professeurs junior qui s'explique bien
sûr à la fois par le retard de
publication du décret afférent et la
persistance de résistance locale les
crédits de paiement non consommés ont
donc été reportés si cela perdurer et la
crainte de Bercy peut-être s'en mêler
avez-vous identifié ce risque et
escomptez-vous une montée en charge du
dispositif
la mesure consistant à consacrer 1% du
budget d'intervention de la NR à la
culture scientifique vous en avez parlé
tout à l'heure ça m'a fait très plaisir
et fait l'objet d'une très bonne
dynamique ce qui me réjouit le président
de la NR nous a donné quelques exemples
très intéressants de projet et on
essaiera j'essaierai de les mettre en
évidence dans le rapport parce qu'il y
avait vraiment des thèmes passionnants
auxquels personne ne s'attendait et je
pense que mes collègues seront
intéressés aussi de d'en avoir quelques
quelques instituts et en effet
primordial d'investir dans la culture
scientifique pour former des consciences
éclairées de demain
un conseil national de la culture
scientifique avait été créée par la loi
fiorazo dont on va bientôt fêter les 10
ans pour faire dialoguer les principaux
acteurs du secteur or il semble que
l'instance soit en déshérence depuis
quelques temps ne pourriez vous pas la
réactiver
quand et comment souhaitez-vous aussi
ouvrir le dossier de la restructuration
du paysage français de la recherche
sachant que le climat c'est un peu tendu
ces derniers temps entre les grands
organismes et les établissements
universités et écoles et dernier point
un petit peu peut-être à la marge mais
qui ne l'est pas pour eux sur l'Institut
Paul-Émile Victor
vous savez que la France a des ambitions
polaires très fortes or l'Agence
nationale de moyens de compétences au
service de la recherche française des
régions des régions polaires l'Institut
Paul-Émile Victor connaît de très grave
difficultés le plafond d'emploi est
complètement sous-dimensionné ce qui
conduit cette institut non seulement à
violer systématiquement le droit du
travail mais l'empêche également de
planifier les travaux de rénovation de
ces stations faut de personnel dédiées à
cette mission est-ce que le Gouvernement
soutiendra donc l'amendement de
l'Assemblée nationale visant à financer
5 et TP supplémentaires quelle solution
envisagez-vous à moyen terme pour
plafonner pour adapter le plafond
d'emploi de cette institut assez réel
besoin par ailleurs alors que les
campagnes d'été sont désormais lancées
de plein par l'explosion des prix des
matières premières du fret maritime et
du transport aérien pourtant le budget
de l'Institut polémie Victor est
reconduit à l'identique dans le projet
de loi finance pour 2023 la commission
du développement durable de l'Assemblée
nationale a voté hier une augmentation
du budget de 3 millions d'euros est-ce
que le gouvernement sera favorable à cet
amendement merci
Stéphane
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je me joins vous remerciement
de leur darkos pour votre
pour votre présentation du budget très
détaillé j'ai un premier point qui va
appeler quatre quatre remarques
successives sur le sujet énergétique qui
évidemment fortement lié au sujet de
l'immobilier universitaire que que
j'évoquerai tout à l'heure d'abord vous
l'avez dit le recours au fond de
roulement que je considère est considéré
comme une solution courte thermiste
fondrement hors réserve de précaution
pour 15 jours de fonctionnement des
établissements pour moi n'est pas
pleinement satisfaisante premièrement
une partie de ces fonds ça a été précisé
déjà fléchée sur des dépenses sur des
actions ou des programmes
d'investissement et leur suspension
compromettrait évidemment le
développement des établissements et
deuxièmement ces fonds sont généralement
le résultat d'une bonne gestion
financière des des marges de manœuvre
pour justement des projets
d'investissement qui sont parfois amenés
à subir quelques
plus value appelez-vous néanmoins
formellement les établissements à puiser
dans leur trésorerie pour faire face à
ces dépenses énergétiques deuxième
remarque le travail de recensement et
d'expertise des usages et des
équipements on va prendre du temps et
ses effets de seront pas visibles ne
seront pas visibles avant courant 2023
voire 2024 si on attend les les
résultats en attendant envisagez-vous
donc des aides exceptionnelles ciblées
sur certains établissements votre
collègue de l'économie a assuré il y a
quelques semaines vouloir trouver des
des moyens pour que les universités
fonctionnent cet hiver pouvez-vous
confirmer cette volonté indiquée dans
quel par quelle mesure cela se
traduirait-il et quelle modalités aussi
de la compensation que vous venez
d'évoquer sans toutefois la chiffrée
est-ce que est-ce que cette compensation
s'adresse à tous les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur ou seulement
une partie d'entre eux et peut-être avec
quelle clé de répartition troisième
remarque une réorganisation de l'année
universitaire qui ferait qui
consisterait à moins concentrer les les
enseignements sur l'automne et l'hiver
est-elle une piste que votre ministère
étudie et quatrième remarque toujours
sur le même sujet pour relayer le
rapport de la Cour des comptes qui a été
rendu public à point nommé la semaine
dernière et vous avez forcément
examiné avec attention c'est un rapport
finalement assez sévère sur l'immobilier
universitaire 18 millions de mètres
carrés et 20% de de l'immo de l'État qui
pointe son financement défaillant de
manière structurelle
partagez-vous les constats de de la Cour
des comptes et comment comptez-vous
redresser la barre êtes-vous favora par
exemple à une possibilité d'emprunt plus
large pour les universités
deuxième point sur les contrats
d'objectif de moyenne performance
auteur de plus de 35 millions cette
année donc il semblerait qu'une douzaine
d'universités pilotes soient concernée
l'année prochaine est-ce que vous pouvez
donner le profil des universités
retenues en quoi consisteront ces
contrats d'objectifs et de moyens on a
parlé de contrepartie un contrat donc
une contrepartie pour les établissements
signataires de ces contrats d'objectifs
et de moyens est-ce qu'on peut envisager
ce que vous envisagez à terme leur
généralisation
troisième point sur la concertation
relative à la vie étudiante et une
mission
d'information sur sur ce point-là
prévoyez-vous d'informer voir d'associer
les parlementaires à la réflexion avec
une dimension territoriale du dossier
qui me paraît central donc je sais que
c'est vraiment de collègues sont
attentifs à vos réponses là-dessus sur
les bourses de critères sociaux donc qui
augmentent de 4%, est-ce que vous
envisagez de mettre sur la table la
question du rattachement au foyer fiscal
des parents qui est une demande
récurrente de syndicats et celle
également de la territorialisation des
de ces bourses
je ne reviens pas sur la réforme de de
des services de santé universitaire que
un peu plus technique mais je terminerai
par un point que je relève chaque année
depuis 2018 je pointe le faible
financement des expliques des
établissements supérieurs d'intérêt
général privé d'intérêt général à
hauteur de 650 euros
par étudiant et par an à comparer aux
11000 à peu près 11000 euros un petit
peu moins par étudiant et par an dans
les établissements publics à mon sens le
label intérêt général doit signifier
quelque chose et doit être accompagné
d'un d'un financement plus conséquent
quel est votre position sur ce point
précis je vous remercie
je vais vous laisser répondre à première
question des deux rapporteurs
donc déjà merci beaucoup pour vos
questions et monsieur le sénateur je
vais commencer donc les questions par
madame la sénatrice donc la compensation
énergétique et peut-être je vais faire
un lot à tous les deux puisque il y
avait un point sur les récompensations
énergétiques sur les onr déjà nous
allons considérer aussi bien évidemment
les on-r je l'ai dit que les
établissements d'enseignements
supérieurs et de recherche
chacun
voilà le CEA par exemple est un gros
consommateur vous l'avez dit par rapport
au nucléaire mais à ces installations
donc il est il s'est même plus entre
guillemets simple puisque ils sont moins
nombreux et que nous avons une gestion
vraiment bilatérale au cas par cas très
très fort une vision très très pointue
sur le état des lieux des budgets et
donc il est clair qu'ils seront suivis
accompagnés comme les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur et ça sera au
cas par cas aussi par rapport à leurs
besoins donc ça ce budget de
compensation qui sera un budget pour
leur permettre plus des consignes de
faire un budget en déficit donc qui sera
couvert au moment du compte puisque
c'est ça la méthode par rapport au fond
de roulement et donc dans je crois que
Monsieur piénor monsieur le sénateur
vous m'avez demandé les modalités donc
en fait nous sommes en train de
l'étudier mais soit il interviendra en
tant que recettes dans le budget 2023
soit au niveau de 2022 il alimentera
finalement le fond de roulement et
finalement sera compensé sur le budget
déficitaire au moment des comptes voilà
c'est en train d'être regardé voilà et
nous donnerons les consignes précises
aussi bien aux établissements cause
universités à la fois de leur enveloppe
de compensation et comment la faire
intervenir dans leur budget 2023 pour
compenser le déficit ça c'est c'est la
règle que on est en train de d'établir
sur donc c'est vraiment du cas par cas
sur le côté en réserve fond de roulement
donc par rapport à la gestion donc vous
l'avez dit il y a une partie réserve des
15 jours de ma salariale mais il y a
aussi une partie projet et donc je parle
bien du fond de roulement disponible
c'est à dire que nous avons une enquête
nous connaissons à l'heure actuelle
l'état des fonds de roulement des
établissements aussi bien organismes que
établissement d'enseignement supérieur
et nous avons ce que j'appelle le fond
de roulement dormant c'est-à-dire celui
qui n'est pas prévu pour des projets et
c'est évidemment sur ce fond de
roulement disponible ce troisième tiers
même c'est pas entière mais cette
troisième partie du fond de roulement
sur lequel nous demandons un acte de
solidarité de responsabilisation aux
établissements parce que le fond de
roulement c'est là pour des crises et je
crois que nous sommes en crise et donc
il est clair que si l'on n'utilise pas
l'effondrement en cette période ben il
ne serviront pas donc soit il servent à
prévoir des projets sur le long terme et
c'est cela pour les bons élèves et je
vous rejoins que nous ne voulons pas
pénaliser donc ils continueront à faire
vos projets parce qu'ils ont prévu du
fond de roulement pour le projet soit il
sert il n'y a pas de prévisions de
projet et c'est du fond de roulement
utilisable en cas de pépin en cas de
crise et c'est celui-là que nous allons
mobiliser pour dans un cadre de crise
pouvoir aussi abandonner les
problématiques de la crise énergétique
mais dans une volonté ne pas assécher
non plus pour pas mettre les
établissements en difficulté sur le
moyen terme et c'est là où nous verrons
comment accompagner ceux qui ne pourront
pas absorber dans leur fonds de
roulement avec ces règles-là le surcoût
et ceux qui pourront la Sorber mais sur
lesquels il est bon de garder quelque
part une enveloppe de sécurité pour
l'avenir alors l'idée est bien sûr et
nous l'avons un tableau de chaque état
de d'établissement d'assurer de
continuer à assurer les 15 jours aux
établissements et la règle ne sera une
règle de répartition au cas par cas au
vu de l'état des lieux du fonds de
roulement de chacun des établissements
ou mécanismes de recherche donc voilà un
petit peu
je comment nous nous allons essayer de
les gérer avec eux dans les jours qui
viennent et dans les semaines qui
viennent au niveau du CPJ donc le
démarrage a été effectivement plus
compliqué plus long pour vous l'avez dit
différentes raisons en particulier aussi
une certaine acceptabilité de ces CPJ
dans les établissements donc qui
viennent de plus en plus nombreux mais
aujourd'hui très très clairement les CPJ
ce sont des crédits fléchés et donc pour
nous il n'est pas question de les
réorienter et a priori nous les
surveillons mais il n'y a pas de danger
pour nous aujourd'hui à perdre ses
crédits fléchés pour les CPJ et qui
seront utilisés pour des postes de type
CPG
ensuite la NR sciences et société donc
merci beaucoup d'avoir heureux parce que
c'est un point effectivement que nous
souhaitons porter fortement sur tous ces
actes de sciences participative de
sciences et sociétés de médiation voilà
et de sciences avec et pour la société
et donc nous regarderons je souhaite
probablement dans le cabinet nommé soit
enfin un chargé de mission ou un délégué
sur ce sujet là et nous regarderons
effectivement nous l'avons bien
identifié le point de ce conseil
national qui est dormant et de regarder
comment nous allons retraiter de
remettre en haut de de je dirais en
fortement présent les problématiques de
sciences avec pour la société donc c'est
un point qu'on va regarder qu'on a bien
noté sur les restructurations des
organismes nous sommes en train d'y
travailler donc je dirais qu'il est déjà
lancé avec eux en discussion et nous
allons très vite lancer des missions
pour rentrer donc c'est une question du
qui vient au mois de octobre novembre ça
va se lancer très concrètement et les
choses ont déjà avancé en discutant avec
les organismes et les universités France
université et U10 et donc nous nous
voyons très régulièrement pour regarder
comment continuer cette transformation
des organismes comme je l'avais présenté
en grande agence de programme et de
recentrer les universités sur leur rôle
territorial et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
on a une vision bien alignée et il faut
la mettre en oeuvre sur l'IPEV donc
l'Institut Paul-Émile Victor alors
d'abord je voudrais dire que l'on est je
suis mais le gouvernement est convaincu
de l'importance de la recherche polaire
que ce soit en Arctique que ce soit en
Antarctique ou dans les îles Sud
antarctiques voilà il y a plusieurs et
que pour tout ce qui est changement
climatique modification de la
circulation
océanique et tout ce qui est sur l'océan
ces stations et cette recherche est
capitale donc je voudrais l'affirmer
pour cela je voudrais quand même
rappeler sans
occulter du tout les manques mais
rappeler le soutien supplémentaire à
l'IPF que le ministère a déjà donné
dernièrement donc il y a un soutien
humain de 11 postes sur trois ans entre
2021 et 2023 donc 2 ont été mis en 2021
7 en 2022 et nous allons en financer à
nouveau cette année pour continuer cette
ce cet apport mais je voudrais insister
que l'IPEV est aujourd'hui confronté à
des difficultés structurelles et même
les postes que nous avons mis ne sont
pas obligatoirement tous pourvu donc les
problématiques de postes et de moyens
que nous avons bien dans dans le viseur
oui tout à fait et la rénovation en
particulier de la station Dumont
d'Urville et je voudrais signaler que
nous avons mis 7,8 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour faire les études
entre 2021 et 2023 du monde d'Urville
donc c'est lancé et les études sont
financées il y a 7 millions d'euros qui
ont été débloqués mais aujourd'hui il y
a un problème structurel qu'il faut
résoudre et nous allons nous en occuper
nous avons commencé à regarder avec en
particulier pour proposer un scénario
d'évolution de l'IPEV avec l'ensemble
des acteurs que nous allons mettre
autour de la table un scénario
d'évolution des stations de rénovation
et je pense qu'il faut regarder les
partenariats européens parce que que ce
soit l'Allemagne que ce soit la Norvège
que ce soit l'Italie avec qui nous
travaillons plus personne ne peut
travailler chacun dans son coin donc il
y a une vision européenne voire
internationale et puis un scénario de
évidemment un bilan attendu pour le
l'année 2023 lié à l'ensemble donc nous
nous donnons jusqu'en début 2023 pour
avoir un plan de travail structurel et
associez ça de moyens pour accompagner
cette évolution les moyens associés je
m'engage par contre pour les
problématiques conjoncturelles sur le
novembre à mars que les frais de mission
nécessaires pour les missions entre
novembre et mars soit on l'a évalué à
peu près un million d'urgence là soit
couvert pour nos bloquer aucune mission
entre nos membres et mars donc nous
allons accompagner la réalisation de ces
missions quantifier les difficultés plus
globales et les accompagner avec une
réflexion plus structurelle pour
accompagner les moyens voilà pour les
fèves
peut-être le je n'ai pas répondu à alors
pardon sur voilà sur l'ensemble des
étudiants donc la réorganisation sur
l'année universitaire c'est aussi
quelque chose sur lequel on va
travailler ce n'est pas encore mais il
faut qu'on se mette tous autour de la
table et ça sera plutôt pour l'année
d'après si s'il y a des modifications
sur l'état des établissements le vous
avez parlé de
du recours à l'emprunt donc sur le et je
vais lier ça au rapport de la Cour des
comptes sur le patrimoine donc il est
clair que ce rapport de la Cour des
comptes clairement on connaît l'état
c'est comme vous l'avez dit de troisième
patrimoine 18 millions de mètres carrés
on l'avait dit la fois dernière donc
d'une part pour l'attractivité et les
conditions de travail de nos collègues
mais aussi l'impact écologique c'est un
point très fort et donc nous sommes en
train de travailler avec Christophe
Béchu et dans le cadre de la
planification écologique à une
proposition d'un pour la pour les
rénovations en transition énergétique et
thermique qui n'est pas exactement sur
l'emprunt mais je dirais dans la même
idée et pour donner une méthodologie un
modèle aux établissements très
rapidement pour pouvoir lancer un grand
plan de rénovation énergétique là nous
espérons pouvoir l'annoncer dans les
semaines où vraiment moi là qui viennent
puisqu'on est en train de travailler
dessus et c'est l'idée de l'emprunt même
si c'est pas exactement décliné de cette
façon là donc sur les les comptes les
contrats d'objectifs et de moyens et de
performance vous avez parlé de 12
universités pilotes alors aujourd'hui
rien n'est décidé en fait nous
travaillons encore la copie pour savoir
effectivement parce que beaucoup
beaucoup d'universités seraient
partantes et donc vous avez posé les
bonnes questions comment définir quel
profil et comment définir 12 une partie
et donc nous sommes en train de définir
une copie avec les points à regarder
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un contrat
d'objectif de moyen la contrepartie
c'est aussi le levier sur les politiques
prioritaires que je vous ai présentées
la dernière fois et aussi sur
l'évolution performance mais c'est
performances d'accompagnement de la
recherche et de l'accompagnement de la
formation évidemment c'est c'est sa
vocation d'être généralisé pour tous les
établissements donc est-ce qu'on le fera
dès la première année pour tous mais
peut-être pas sur tous les points est-ce
qu'on le fera sur certains et en
généralisera nous n'avons pas encore
fixé la méthode complètement voilà il y
aura plusieurs je dirais point regarder
avec les établissements certains sur
leur demande et d'autres sur notre
demande à nous et nos politiques
prioritaires sur la vie étudiante oui
bien sûr la mission va être lancée donc
cette mission que j'ai confié au recteur
qui est une mission de territoire pour
regarder la vie étudiante avec tous les
acteurs de territoire les collectivités
les régions les CROUS et bien évidemment
vous serez associés nous avons demandé
au recteur mais nous sommes encore en
train de définir un petit peu le
périmètre et la façon parce que chacun
le définit un peu différemment suivant
son territoire et l'état des lieux
sur les bourses donc sur la
territorialisation des bourses donc
aujourd'hui nous allons nous lançons la
concertation sur ces bourses donc je ne
peux pas dire ce qui sera fait ou pas
puisque c'est vraiment une concertation
que nous souhaitons à la fois au niveau
national et sur la vie étudiante de
façon plus large au niveau territorial
mais le point sur la territorialisation
sera posée sera
regardé pour voir les impacts j'ai nommé
un délégué interministériel pour cette
concertation qui est Jean-Michel jaulion
et qui va suivre cette concertation en
particulier en lien vie étudiante et sur
les bourses et
aujourd'hui je ne veux pas laisser
penser que rien n'existe pour les jeunes
pour tout ce qui est jeune et étudiant
en rupture familiale ou qui sortent une
certaine autonomie ou plutôt
indépendance de rupture c'est sa
familiale il y a des aides de CROUS il y
a des aides exceptionnelles du CROUS
pour ces jeunes là qui ne sont pas sur
le foyer fiscal ou qui deviennent bien
indépendants et donc tout cela va être
regardé suivant chaque situation de ces
jeunes et de ses étudiants
et les Espig je sais que ça vous tient à
cœur donc je ne voudrais pas l'oublier
le dernier point donc effectivement les
espigues il y a eu tout une évolution
des espigues qui est qui a diminué
pendant certaines années vous l'avez
rappelé pour tomber à environ 600 euros
ces dernières années je voudrais juste
rappeler qu'il y a eu depuis plusieurs
années une compensation à cette
diminution puisque il y a eu en 2021 une
subvention qui a été augmentée de 9
millions d'euros et que la pente se
redresse un petit peu donc nous et cette
année dans les circonstances que nous
avons nous avons compensé la démographie
pour les esprits comme les autres d'un
million d'euros pour maintenir et ne pas
descendre au niveau de ce coup par
étudiant avec une volonté de maintien
dans le contexte tendu économiquement
merci Madame amis c'est la parole à
Jean-Pierre Moga j'ai oublié de saluer
je m'en excuse auprès
de la commission des affaires
économiques importantes pour avis sur
les crédits de la recherche merci madame
la ministre monsieur le Président merci
cher collègue d'abord monsieur le
Président je voudrais vous remercier de
me permettre de participer à cette
audition bien que n'appartenant pas
comme vous l'avez dit à la commission de
la culture et de l'éducation madame la
ministre je me permets de vous
questionner en tant donc rapporteur
budgétaire d'un commission des affaires
économiques sur les crédits de la
recherche
ma question fait également écho rapport
rendu par la mission d'information sur
l'innovation à laquelle j'ai participé
nous avions eu d'ailleurs l'honneur de
vous auditionner dans le cadre de vos
anciennes fonctions
je reste convaincu que la France a une
vision trop linéaire de l'innovation
conduisant les pouvoirs publics à
soutenir c'est le si essentiellement au
travers d'appel à projets qui ne
permettent pas de construire des
feuilles de route industrielles et
technologiques et ne permet surtout pas
d'avoir une vision en moyenne ou à long
terme que nécessite la recherche et
l'innovation
mais avant toute mesure il me semble
qu'il convient de solutionner la
problématique que représente
l'enseignement scientifique de notre
pays
les besoins de l'économie française en
termes de nouveaux ingénieurs sont
estimés entre 50 et 60000 diplômés
chaque année si l'on en froid la
Conférence des directeurs des écoles
françaises d'ingénieurs nos écoles n'en
forment que 33 000 par an
le différentiel
continuent de causer les années passant
un affaissement important de notre
compétitivité concernant les doctorats
si après une force baisse leur nombre
réaugmentent légèrement leur nom est
encore inférieur je crois celui de
2009 dès lors comment comptez-vous
concrètement attirer durant les
prochaines années davantage d'élèves
vers nos écoles d'ingénieurs vers les
doctorats afin de répondre aux besoins
de notre de notre économie
la loi de programmation
c'est un aimable a permis des avancées
vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure dans
un contexte en plus difficile que nous
vivons et que nous allons continuer à
vivre donc j'avais une question je
considère que j'ai répondu sur la
rénover la la rémunération
des enseignants mais dans vos propos
liminaires et à répondant aux questions
de de mes collègues dont je ne vous
reposerai pas de questions là-dessus je
souhaite simplement que ce que le
gouvernement mettra en oeuvre permettre
d'attirer de conserver le maximum de
talents sur notre territoire Sylvie
Robert
[Musique]
merci beaucoup madame la ministre pour
vos propos et votre engagement donc que
nous saluons
et ça n'est pas mes collègues le savent
rien de le dire aujourd'hui
trois points de suspense
non plus sérieusement mais en fait
j'étais très sincère vraiment vraiment
toujours oui oui en général c'est j'ai
deux petites questions vous avez parlé
de la compensation du point d'indice les
360 millions d'euros sur les
établissements d'enseignement je voulais
simplement savoir si dans le périmètre
les contractuels étaient intégrés ça
c'était ma première question et ma
deuxième question concerne les CROUS
alors vous l'avez vraiment
bien dit et j'ai bien noté les
compensations les 50 millions d'euros
les nouveaux postes de travailleurs
sociaux on peut dire que les postes les
CROUS ont joué un rôle très important
pendant
pendant les le confinement enfin je ne
reviendrai pas là-dessus parce qu'on l'a
salué repas 1 euro les etc etc pour
autant est-ce que vous pensez que
l'enveloppe financière à louer par
rapport au coût énergétique par rapport
à la hausse de l'inflation notamment sur
les denrées alimentaires
vont suffire et je le dis non pas en
pointant un CROUS parce que moi en
Bretagne il est vraiment enfin voilà il
a joué un rôle et il continue un jour un
rôle important et bien sûr je pense dans
l'ensemble de nos territoires mais il y
a quelques petites augmentations sur les
repas
donc qui qui voilà qui forcément
interpelle pas complètement mais je
pense que ça peut peut-être être un
problème je pense que les contraintes
sont vraiment réelles voilà je le dis
comme ça et du coup je terminerai pour
être très très courte plus
substantiellement quel regard
portez-vous sur le rapport de la Cour
remonte qui appelle à une révision de
leur modèle économique au regard de
vraiment l'évolution de leur mission
voilà ça c'est question un peu plus
prospective mais
on sait qu'en tout cas ils ont joué ils
jouent un rôle important et ils ont
beaucoup beaucoup de missions qui qui
donc voilà modèle économique merci
beaucoup
le docteur Pierre aux oyos donc pas
encore professeur merci
je suis le président madame la ministre
merci beaucoup pour la clarté de de
votre propos moi j'aurais moi j'aurais
eu envie de questionner une personne qui
n'est pas avec vous là à côté et qui
pourtant tient les clés du problème de
l'université c'est Monsieur Bercy
donc je m'adresserai monsieur Bercy
parce que je me suis déjà adressé à
plusieurs reprises à lui et notamment en
juillet dans le cadre de la loi de
finance rectificative ou on savait déjà
que certaines universités n'avaient pas
les moyens budgétaires pour faire la
rentrée aujourd'hui la situation vous
l'a dit elle s'y a gravée parce que
c'est ajouté à ça les surcos
énergétiques les problèmes de non
compensation des trois et demi pour cent
et on a le sentiment qu'elles vont être
dans l'obligation toute l'année d'allait
quémander excusez-moi le verbe à Bercy
des moyens supplémentaires pour assurer
leur leur mission de service public il y
a une forme de curatelle budgétaire qui
est complètement opposé à l'esprit de
l'autonomie des universités on va
l'inverse il y a une mise sous tutelle
ce que ce que je comprends pas c'est que
notre humanité je le dis de façon un peu
solennelle elle est face à des défis qui
sont absolument majeur et qu'on ne
pourra pas régler sans la connaissance
sans la formation sans un engagement
massif et historique dans l'université
et dans la recherche et la question un
peu un peu brutale que j'ai envie de
vous poser c'est pourquoi les élites
françaises n'aiment pas l'université
il y a un mal français profond qui fait
que alors qu'on voit bien que leur
situation est dramatique et que si les
orsilés les étudiants sortent dans la
rue la réquisition marchera pas madame
la ministre
il faudra les gérer et je pense que ça
coûtera beaucoup plus cher à ce moment
là à Bercy de trouver les moyens de les
faire rentrer dans les dans les
universités alors pour essayer d'être un
peu un peu concret moi j'aimerais vous
poser
deux questions simples la première le
Gouvernement a souhaité si tu es une
très bonne mesure essayée de former
25000 au fonctionnaires
au problème de la transition énergétique
de la transition climatique ils seront
formés essentiellement par lianesp
pourquoi pas l'université est-ce que
est-ce que vraiment c'était nécessaire
de passer encore une fois par cette
filière qui qui va sans doute glaner
quelques fonds au passage donc ils ont
pas besoin peut-être que ça aurait été
un symbole fort que l'université puisse
former c'est au fonctionnaires et ma
deuxième question c'est le dispositif
des coffrets alors convention de
formation pour la recherche en
administration c'est l'équivalent
simplifie des chiffres pour
l'administration madame vinal avait pris
l'engagement ici devant cette commission
c'était en mars 2022 de créer une
centaine de coffrage résultat je crois
que dans le budget il y en a à peu près
une dizaine et là aussi le signal est
catastrophique le signal est
catastrophique parce que nous sommes
tous d'accord pour considérer que en
France il faut absolument restaurer la
valeur du doctorat et notamment dans
l'administration française
je ferai pas le décompte des membres du
gouvernement coin un doctorat vous en
faites partie mais quand on compare avec
le gouvernement allemand on se dit que
parfois on comprend pourquoi les élites
ne connaissent pas l'université donc là
il y avait un moyen de rapprocher les
demandes je regrette vraiment que des
engagements qui ont été précis ne soient
pas tenus merci Madame les ministres
oui merci monsieur le Président cher
Laurent madame la ministre même si
différentes questions vous ont déjà été
posées notamment sur l'énergie la
situation sociale des étudiants moi j'ai
quelques questions en commençant par le
fait que les universités ont salué les
différents budgets que vous avez pu
porter contre la lutte contre les
violences sexistes sexuelles la mobilité
la compagnement des étudiants en
situation de handicap néanmoins
certaines associations féministes
étudiantes critique vivement le fait que
les montants concernant les violences
sexistes et sexuelles par nom soit
quatre fois inférieur à celle de la
santé pensez-vous que ces montants
soient suffisant j'avais une question
aussi un peu plus
centres et centrale notamment porté par
la FAGE mais Stéphane piénoir a déjà
porté la question sur les
territorialisation des des bourses
étudiantes comme quoi tout arrive et
peut-être tu vois tout arrive une
question une question un peu plus à
droite à étudiants et syndicats
dénoncent l'exclusion des hommes d'un
atelier informatique organisé par le
service culturel de l'Université comment
réagissez-vous à cette nouvelle
polémique tout comme réagissez-vous
comment réagissez-vous aux propos du
député Louis Boyard qui appelle à
l'insurrection dans les universités lors
d'une conférence à Strasbourg
Bernard docteur
excusez-moi moi je reviens sur l'égalité
des chances dans l'accès aux grandes
écoles
cette année on aurait 83000 étudiants en
place préparatoire il y en a 63% dans
les classes scientifiques 23 filières
économiques 14 littéraires on s'aperçoit
que les filières scientifiques et
littéraires et bien les préparations
publiques les classes préparatoires
publiques donne de très bons résultats
en revanche pour les matières
économiques sur le classement des 10
classes préparatoires qui envoient le
plus d'élèves il y en a sept qui sont
privés avec une moyenne
de coûts de 5000 euros par an est-ce que
comptait faire qu'à même quelque chose
pour que les préparatoires publics
puissent retrouver leur place dans le
même état d'esprit celui des
des études de médical et les officines
qui accompagnent les étudiants votre
prédécesseur nous avait annoncé avait
annoncé que avec l'ouverture du
numérique clausus à réglerait le
problème il y en a jamais eu autant
cette année et jamais autant aussi cher
alors certaines facultés veulent mettre
en place un tutorat et des préparatoires
qui soient pris est-ce qu'il y aura des
moyens qui leur seront donnés ce que
c'est quelque chose qui est incité et
qui est accompagné
petit point près sur le la recherche en
mathématiques donc il y a eu des
questions tout à l'heure
saignement
secondaire mais aussi sur l'université
on s'aperçoit qu'il y a de moins en
moins de professeurs qui qui viennent il
y a de plus en plus
d'étudiants malgré tout et des tâches
administratives des tâches
d'enseignement ça veut dire qu'il y a un
temps consacré à la recherche qui qui
diminue alors on peut faire face avec
les chair de professeurs juniors je
voulais savoir comment vous évaluez
après deux ans d'exercice et
c'est cher professeur junior et puis sur
ses chers votre prédécesseur toujours
s'est engagé auprès des syndicats de
dire qu'à chaque création d'une chair il
y aurait aussi une une création
de professeur classique est-ce que c'est
bien tenu dans ce domaine et enfin pour
reprendre un peu à propos de collègues
Moga
le crédit d'impôt recherche
est-ce qu'on en a une une évaluation
est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui qui
marche quel est votre avis dans dans ce
domaine
je reviendrai pas sur la vie étudiante
j'ai compris que c'est un problème
central mais qui va être territorialisé
donc je suis encore en pleine réflexion
sur la sémantique
toutes vos questions comme ça ça
permettra à la ministre de répondre de
manière globale
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président
en matière de propos préliminaires je ne
serai jamais aussi élégant de Robert
donc je m'abstiendrai tout vous a été
dit il faut rien dire je vais simplement
poser
quelques petites caisses rapides
questions en complément des questions
qui ont été posées par un auteur
rapporteur pour avis par ces familles
noires et leurs darkos alors je sais pas
si ma question sera centriste ou
centrale sur la tête sur la
territorialisation
de du système de bourse on sait que les
collectivités locales les communautés
d'agglomération les régions
font beaucoup de dispositifs d'aide et
donc cette concertation avec les
collectivités va et de bon sens
semble-t-il est-ce que cela pourrait
aller jusqu'à une guichet unique qui
faciliterait passablement la vie des
étudiants est-ce que cela fait partie
des objectifs de ladite concertation
territoriale centrale et centriste
concernant la vie étudiante
je
ne vous vendrai pas votre avis sur les
propos tenus par la président de la
Région Île-de-France concernant le
transfert de la compétence vie étudiante
aux régions il n'empêche que là aussi
quand on parle de vie étudiante les
régions les communautés les métropoles
ou les communautés d'agglomération
jouent en rôle important vous êtes en
concertation de terrain pour reprendre
les propos que j'ai tenu au journal Le
Monde le 15 septembre jusqu'où
comptez-vous aller dans ce partenariat
c'est voilà le tout premier question
complément de sécurité posée par Stephen
piloire concernant la recherche et les
questions qui vous ont déposées par leur
darkos
d'abord je crois qu'on est très heureux
de vous avoir entendu parler des bourses
de doctorat tout à l'heure et de dire
que vous allez raisonner on passe
simplement en flux en stock et c'est une
excellente journée autant lactée et le
poser fortement
est-ce qu'on peut en savoir un peu plus
je suis un petit peut-être impatient sur
les mécanismes qui restent à préciser
est-ce que vous pouvez vous en dire
davantage faudrait aussi revenir en deux
mots sur la LPR et me rappeler des
débats que nous avons eu dans cette
commission et dans l'hémicycle
sur la non prise en compte de
l'inflation dans la projection lorsque
nous discutions avec Madame Vidal
voire même avec Bercy cher Pierre Julia
si nous était répondu
que l'inflation avait disparu depuis 15
ans et qu'on se voit bien pourquoi elle
reviendrait
malheureusement il est là
et n'est pas et aucun mécanisme de
revalorisation lié à l'inflation n'est
dans le prévu dans le cadre de LPR
donc vous nous avez dit des choses
intéressantes sur l'énergie
et nous vous attendrons vos propositions
mais je vous ai entendu dire aussi
qu'elle s'était profondément
conjoncturelles
je n'en suis pas sûr
et donc je pose vraiment la question
savoir s'il n'y a pas nécessité
d'aborder la réalité de cette
préservation de la LPR et vous avez
parlé et dont nous vous remercions dans
le 4 de ce ensemble de travail de
travaux d'autres ministère par rapport
aux questions d'inflation et d'énergie
enfin une question plus et pas en
complément de celle posée par les
rapporteurs je voudrais vous interroger
sur la formation des professeurs du
second degré qui dépend de désinfects
qui dépendent donc de votre autorité du
moins dans le cadre de l'autonomie des
établissements universitaires la loi
pour une école de la confiance vous le
savez voulait t'inscrire les masters
meufs
comme le cursus prépondérant pour
préparer au métier du professorat trois
ans après le vote de la loi nous en
sommes très loin comment expliquer vous
et peut-être avec une réponse un peu
plus circonstanciée que celle que j'ai
obtenu du président de France université
récemment à votre place le décalage de
la date de concours
demeure en AM2 a eu un effet mécanique
sur les fondements du nombre de
candidats passés dans certaines
disciplines en dessous de la barre du
nombre de postes ouverts pensez-vous
qu'il ne s'agit que d'un effet mécanique
conjoncturel ou est-ce révélateur d'une
crise structurelle
quel est le travail que vous faites sur
le sujet avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et je cours terminerai en
pointant la question qui a déjà été
évoquée de réduction du vivier des
futures professeurs de mathématiques et
qui est parti en préoccupant
et sur lequel on peut voir quelques
inquiétudes vu de la réponse
plutôt rapide du ministre de l'éducation
nationale il y a quelques instants dans
l'hémicycle de questions de l'ordre
d'arcoste donc comment allons et vous
ensemble avec le ministre éducation
nationale régler cette question très
préoccupante du vivier des futurs
professeurs de mathématiques dans notre
pays
[Musique]
oui merci merci monsieur le Président la
ministre chers collègues je vous
remercie pour votre présentation bien
détaillée alors beaucoup de réponses ont
été apportées
si je salue la hausse des crédits il y a
une base positive mais il y a également
des choses qui je vous avouent me déçoit
même un petit peu sur le programme 231
et notamment sur la vie étudiante c'est
la précarité étudiante on a parlé des
bourses sur critères sociaux qui ont ils
sont revalorisés mais écoute des
étudiants de classe moyenne qui
pâtissent tout autant de cette précarité
les loyers des résidences universitaires
d'écrou sont gelés très bien mais quid
des très nombreux étudiants n'ayant pas
pu avoir de place en résidence escrocs
obligés de se loger dans le parc privé
le repas dans les restaurants
universitaires du coup c'est un euro
pour les étudiants boursiers et sans
difficulté après analyse et critères
dans les réputation n'est pas si simple
que ça couille une fois encore des
étudiants issus des classes moyennes
je regarde sincèrement on en avait parlé
que le repas 1 euro était n'est pas été
maintenu pour tous les étudiants cité
d'investissement plus coûteux c'est sûr
mais si utile pour aider nos jeunes
par contre ce qui est totalement absent
c'est l'absence de solution pour les
étudiants d'enseignement supérieur qui
ne sont pas sur des grands campus nous
en avons déjà discuté je sais que vous
êtes en train de travailler sur les
dispositifs
mais solution avait été proposées et ont
été proposées même s'ils ne se sont pas
c'est pas totalement idée de ma PPL sur
le ticket restaurant qui était reprise
vous le savez bien
ce qui est important madame Nice c'est
de proposer des solutions à ceux qui
étudie dans les zones blanches du CROUS
pour ces étudiants pas de résidence
universitaires pas de restauration
étudiante pas de solutions proposées
sans vouloir faire de jeu mauvais jeu de
mots ce programme 231 sur le précarité
alimentaire me laisse sur ma faim
vous savez la ministre est encore temps
de proposer des solutions nous sommes
quelques jours quelques semaines de
l'examen du budget je sais que vous êtes
en train de travailler sur des solutions
il est temps de les proposer des
étudiants sont en attente ces étudiants
de zone blanche vous savez sont en
attente parce que pour eux il y a que un
repas par jour quand c'est quand c'est
le cas ou quand on veut pas le soir pas
de repas le week-end des difficultés
pour se déplacer aujourd'hui avec la
crise de l'énergie et donc
je vous demande ce que vous avez prévu
et si vous pouvez nous annoncer
aujourd'hui peut-être ou dans quelques
jours ce que vous avez l'intention de
faire pour ces hommes blanches merci
Sonia de la pauvreté
[Musique]
oui madame la ministre moi je vais me
contenter de de me contenter d'un sujet
important néanmoins mais de questions
qui concernent la réforme d'accès aux
études de santé
[Musique]
d'abord vous donc vous aviez d'ailleurs
confirmé lors de la précédente audition
qui aurait pas de réforme dans la
réforme c'est à dire que la réforme
serait maintenue en revanche bon le
deuxième rapport à montrer qu'il y avait
encore des ajustements à mettre en
oeuvre et donc qu'elle qu'elle est la
nature de ces ajustements notamment pour
avoir une réforme lisible en sachant
qu'on est encore en amont de parcoursup
et que pour l'instant il y a encore un
certain nombre de sujets qui sont pas
comment dire clavier clarifier
et il serait utile de façon à ce qui est
pas une
[Musique]
donc il est notamment
non seulement urgent du revaloriser la
filière mais sur surtout de auprès des
lycéens et quels sont les levés les
leviers d'action que vous souhaitez
mettre en oeuvre puisque de toute façon
depuis le début on a quand même
considéré que l'information auprès des
lycéens de la mise en œuvre de la
réforme reste quand même quelque chose
de techniquement très compliqué et de
difficilement appréhensible préensible
par eux je vous remercie Alexandra
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre vous le savez depuis quelques
années en plus des frais bien
d'inscription il y a une taxe qui
s'ajoute aux étudiants c'est la
contribution de vie étudiante qui
demeure pour beaucoup d'ailleurs une
incompréhension pour ceux qui doivent
s'en acquitter le pouvoir d'achat des
étudiants étant chute libre cette taxe
vient donc grever leur budget déjà
restreint alors j'avais souhaité attirer
l'attention du Gouvernement sur ce sujet
lors du dernier PLFR via un amendement
d'ailleurs cosiné par une cinquantaine
de collègues interpellés aussi par des
étudiants dans leur département à un
moment que je défendrai de nouveau dans
le prochain PLF la CVEC qui poursuit
donc un objectif tout à fait honorable
mais qui ne doit pas se faire à mon sens
au détriment de nos étudiants et de leur
pouvoir d'achat
sur les
137,9 millions d'euros de cette impôts
savez-vous combien sont fléchés vers le
réseau des œuvres universitaires
envisagez-vous une mesure pour ne pas
accentuer davantage la précarisation de
la condition étudiante enfin je vous
rappelle pour info
fragilisé par l'inflation 79% des
étudiants à vous avoir sollicité pour la
première fois une aide alimentaire
auprès d'une association
[Musique]
pourriez-vous nous dire si le gel des
loyers sur les logements CROUS
concernent aussi le gel des charges
vous répondrez
voilà je vous laisse la parole pour
répondre à ces différentes questions
alors
[Musique]
j'essaye de reprendre messieurs et
Madame les sénateurs dans l'ordre parce
qu'il y en a eu beaucoup de questions
donc j'essaierai de couper monsieur le
sénateur Maugat tout d'abord sur les
points sur comment je vais résumer
attirer plus de doctorants ou activés
plus par la suite alors c'est une très
bonne question déjà à tirer et valoriser
le doctorat je vais grouper la question
avec la valorisation du doctorat en
France qui pour moi reste aussi une
question je pense qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement la LPR mais vous l'avez
dit vous l'avez dit va permettre
d'augmenter de 20% le nombre de
doctorats donc c'est important je
rappelle que on a doublé le nombre de
contratsifs donc les bourses de thèse
avec les entreprises donc ça si c'est un
point important nous avons parlé des
coffrage et reviendrai tout à l'heure
mais en tout cas c'est un point aussi
donc il y a une augmentation globale du
nombre de contrats doctorats en cours
qui est vraiment non négligeable et je
pense qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui il y a
aussi tous les contrats doctorats donc
ça c'est les contrats je dirais avec un
financement direct mais il y a aussi
tous les contrats doctorats à travers
les contrats ANR je vous rappelle aussi
que la NR a augmenté au niveau des taux
de succès avec aujourd'hui 23% mais nous
allons atteindre les 30 %, ce qui va
donner une augmentation aussi de
contrats doctorat important parce que
dans tous les contrats presse knr il y a
des doctorants et je rappelle aussi les
plans d'investissement d'avenir France
2030 dont j'ai parlé c'est 13 milliards
qu'il va y avoir en partie une grosse
partie sur la recherche et en
particulier avec les programmes
d'équipements prioritaire de recherche
ces programmes d'équipements de
prioritaires de recherche sont des
programmes de l'or de 50 millions 80
millions suivant leur thématique et des
grands volets de doctorat sont dedans je
rappelle pour le cantique aussi pour les
SN1 nous avons un volet particulier tout
ce qui est stratégie nationale
d'accélération l'hydrogène le quantique
c'est en plus des ces projets programmes
il un projet pour les doctorats aussi
donc effectivement en plus de la LPR en
plus du doublement des CIF des coffrets
vous avez des augmentations de budget
soit ciblés doctorants sur certaines
thématiques soit dans des contrats ou en
règle générale il y a une partie
doctorale donc je pense que dans les
années à venir nous ne manquerons pas en
tout cas de recruter des doctorats mais
nous devons aussi travailler à la
valorisation du doctorat à travers les
entreprises françaises et tous les
secteurs français et je rejoins ce qui a
été dit aussi dans la fonction publique
donc nous suivons cela de très près
je voudrais revenir madame Robert sur
même si la compensation du point
d'indice oui c'est les contractuels sont
comprises sont compris pardon et je
voudrais rajouter que la compensation
touchera tout fonctionnaire contractuel
tout ce qui touche le
financement par dans le plafond état
tout ce qui touche financement plafond
Etat sera compensé aux établissements
organismes université école c'est très
clair l'ensemble sur les CROUS et par
rapport au coût énergétique
coût inflation etc d'abord je il y avait
une augmentation sur les repas là j'ai
pas bien compris parce que les coûts des
repas sont gelés sont bloqués aussi un
peu comme les croods les loyers donc je
vous rappelle quand même et ça me permet
de répondre à d'autres questions sur les
classes moyennes il y a le repas 1 euro
mais on oublie souvent qu'aujourd'hui le
repas 1 euro est venu pendant la crise
pour aider et compenser entièrement au
niveau du CROUS entre 3,30 et 1 3 30
étant le tarif bloqué depuis trois ans
aussi au niveau des CROUS c'est déjà un
tarif social très très fort et donc nos
étudiants et nos étudiants tous mangent
à un tarif 3 30 midi et soir s'il le
souhaite donc je pense que c'est déjà un
effort très fort que nous bloquons par
rapport en particulier je pense au
classement moyenne ce tarif social de 3
30 et on sait qui est accompagné par
l'écrousse aussi ce qui n'empêche pas et
j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure les zones
blanches et on y reviendra tout à
l'heure particulièrement et donc il
éclaire que sur les crouses pour
terminer sur la pointe je ne reviens pas
sur l'accompagnement effectivement de
l'inflation mais aux augmentations que
nous avons eu j'ai parlé de l'égali avec
les 4 millions d'euros ce qui n'est pas
une petite somme pour compenser au
niveau égalim donc il y a eu un effort
particulier sur le budget cette année
très clairement
sur les le modèle économique il est
clair que nous devons avoir accompagné
aujourd'hui les CROUS et le knous dans
un modèle économique logement
restauration et avec en considérant des
partenariats beaucoup plus global et
donc en cela je rejoins ce que l'on va
faire c'est à dire les discussions de
dialogue territoriales avec les acteurs
territoriaux je pense qu'aujourd'hui
nous devons donc vers des modèles un peu
différents
multipartenaires multilateurs dans
lequel les CROUS le cnouz continuent à
jouer bienment pleinement son rôle mais
c'est un travail que nous devons faire
effectivement sur ce modèle économique
et sur son évolution avec des acteurs
territoriaux des bailleurs sociaux et
avec une vision plus globale pour
répondre aux problématiques de logement
et aussi de restauration alors ça me
permet peut-être de répondre sur la
partie
restauration sur le point parce que
c'est pareil enfin c'est pareil c'est la
même idée finalement c'est à dire que
pour aller on est vraiment conscient et
merci de remettre je dirais à table
puisque vous aviez très faim mais sur la
table le sujet qui est un sujet
important donc on y travaille vous le
savez monsieur le sénateur ainsi qu'avec
monsieur le Président et monsieur
ouzulias nous sommes en plein
comment dire définition d'un nouveau
principe et ce principe c'est aussi avec
des partenaires donc en donnant si
possible axé au niveau des marchés de la
centrale d'achat du CROUS à différents
partenaires collectivités ou autres et
c'est là où on voit déjà cette ouverture
à des partenaires territoriaux donc
c'est pour ça que et donc je pense que
outre les économies d'échelle pour le
réseau des œuvres à faire outre les
économies que peuvent faire ces
partenaires en incluant aussi les
étudiants en plus comme client et je
pense que ça peut être un nouveau modèle
dans lequel il faut que l'on donne et
que l'on trouve très rapidement mais
vous le savez cette piste que nous avons
à l'étude actuellement requiert une
évolution en fait législative pour la
mettre en oeuvre pour amplifier cette
action et pour laquelle nous sommes en
train de chercher le bon véhicule pour
pouvoir porter cette cette mesure donc
c'est en cours avec vous et je pense que
j'espère que nous allons pouvoir aboutir
très rapidement et pouvoir trouver des
zones d'expérimentation très rapidement
cette année pour pouvoir expérimenter
cette ouverture de centrale d'achat du
CROUS à des partenaires
donc ce qui me permet de rappeler donc
monsieur ouzulias mais je voudrais quand
même revenir sur les le rôle des
universités avec le focus sur les la
formation par les 25000 fonctionnaires
cadres de l'État sur tout ce qui est
transition écologique par l'ISP par
rapport aux universités et donc
l'amour des universités ou la
reconnaissance je peux vous dire qu'en
tant que ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la Recherche professeur
des universités je crois profondément à
un système universitaire pluriel
c'est-à-dire qu'on a un système
particulier en France qui est en train
d'évoluer dans lequel nous avons des
richesses et dans lequel nous faisons
évoluer toutes ces richesses et qui je
pense fera prendre à l'université avec
un grand tu dans le d'un modèle plus
lisible à l'international mais en
profitant aussi de nos spécificités
quelque chose de beaucoup plus fort on
est sur cette route on a une évolution
des université en France incroyable
depuis 10 ans une reconnaissance qui
monte et une reconnaissance qui monte
dans un modèle global donc moi je ça me
permet de le redire et j'y crois bien et
dans cette formation des fonctionnaires
les chercheurs des organismes et des
universités seront impliquées puisque
aujourd'hui à travers en particulier les
Grecs qui sont les groupements régionaux
sur l'environnement et le climat avec
des chercheurs
l'infp et les formations vont faire
appel aux chercheurs à travers les
greffes pour participer aux formations
et aux fonctionnaires de l'État donc
nous avons une implication au niveau du
ministère je vous rappelle que
l'ouverture et le lancement de ces
formations j'y étais avec effectivement
les différents ministres en charge et en
particulier Stanislas Guérini de la
fonction publique nous travaillons main
dans la main avec Stanislas Guerini et
le ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
et la recherche j'étais bien présente ce
jour-là parce que nos experts nos
chercheurs vont participer activement
aux formations des
les coffrets pour parler des bourses
c'est un point je nous savons bien ça
effectivement la création d'une centaine
de coffre à part je pense qu'il n'y a
pas qu'un problème de budget il y a un
problème de création d'emploi il y a un
problème aussi de publicité de
reconnaissance dans les différents
administrations et donc nous continuons
à y travailler nous allons y travailler
pour atteindre les objectifs qui avaient
été fixés et le problème est un peu
multiple avec aussi ces points de
création d'emploi de plafond d'emploi
sur les montants
mais je regarde les futurs
monsieur voilà Monsieur engrais je suis
ovss monsieur le sénateur donc est-ce
suffisant ou pas je pense que
les problèmes de violence sexuelle et
sexistes nous sommes en train de les
accompagner et en fait le doublement du
budget avant de savoir vous savez il
faut toujours savoir à quoi ça sert
faire un bilan pour ensuite voir ce qui
manque et pouvoir et non nous sommes
dans cette vision d'amélioration
continue et d'accompagnement continue et
donc ce doublement du budget va
permettre de constituer une équipe avec
des postes de dans chaque région pour
pouvoir accompagner les établissements
dans l'amélioration tout le monde
aujourd'hui a bien pris en compte ce
problème mais dans l'amélioration de la
mise en place de leur cellules de leur
procédure on sait encore aujourd'hui que
ben voilà cet accompagnement aussi bien
sur le volet législatif que
disciplinaire que d'accompagnement des
étudiants et des étudiants sur la santé
et etc les référents il reste des
progrès et donc nous avons ciblé des
actions précises avec ce doublement que
nous allons mettre en place que nous
allons suivre et avant enfin de toute
façon c'est comme certains actions on
peut toujours trouver mais je pense que
il y a vraiment un moment donné où se
poser pour voir où en sont nos
établissements dans la
professionnalisation de l'accompagnement
de la VS et c'est l'objectif de ce
doublement DVSS voilà donc ce budget de
doubler me paraît déjà une bonne chose
dans cette étape d'amélioration
continuer d'accompagnement
sur vous m'avez interpellé sur ce que je
pensais sur l'insurrection ou autre
sujet je n'y reviendrai pas sur le
détail mais ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que moi je suis une fervente je
crois beaucoup en ce qu'on appelle le
service public et la République et ce
qu'on appelle les valeurs de la
République et dans ces valeurs de la
République elle est basée sur des règles
aussi et sur des droits et des devoirs
et je pense que nous devons appliquer
des valeurs et ses règles qui font la
base de notre République et c'est
là-dessus que je m'appuierais par
rapport à ces différentes
interpellations que nous avons
actuellement
sur le point me suffit l'air de la
légalité des chances de l'accès aux
grandes écoles autre donc en particulier
les préparateurs publics ou les
officines de médecine j'en fais un petit
peu paquet sur déjà beaucoup d'action si
je prends les officines privées de
médecine le tutorat en PACES exit depuis
très longtemps et t'accompagnée dans les
facultés de médecine ou facultés des
sciences pour les tutorats et le passage
en passe là continue et il y a des
tutorats qui vont s'accompagner et nous
réfléchissons à avoir des mentorats ou
des tutorats aussi pour aller dans les
lycées ou dans les collèges mais lycées
dans des zones un peu reculées rurales
pour pouvoir montrer aussi à ces jeunes
qui pourraient revenir dans ses déserts
donc il y a toute une réflexion beaucoup
plus globale du tutorat et du mentorat
d'accompagnement d'accéder à des études
de médecine ou de grandes écoles ou
autres pour aussi naturellement je
dirais pouvoir revenir dans des zones
blanches dites blanches par la suite
donc besoin de tutorat qui est un
accompagnement pendant les études mais
aussi un accompagnement avant les études
pour les attirer et pour résoudre à
terme quelques problèmes liés aux
problématiques de santé ou d'autres
parce que l'accès aux études du
supérieur type les grandes écoles on a
un peu les mêmes c'est-à-dire nous
essayons de travailler dessus évidemment
avec le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale sur comment avoir pourquoi
cette attractivité cette compréhension
et cette aide à tous les niveaux par
cette notion de tutorat et de mentorat
qui est déjà soutenu financièrement et
nous regarderons s'il y a besoin de
soutien parce qu'elle va se développer
financièrement ça fait partie et ça me
donne l'occasion mais je réponds en même
temps des discussions que l'on a avec
les conférences de doyen et le comité de
suivi en particulier sur le RAC
c'est-à-dire la réforme du premier cycle
de ce qu'il faut pour pouvoir résoudre
quels sont les moyens etc donc ce point
fait partie aussi et nous sur le point
de la pharmacie il y a la conférence des
doyens de pharmaciens qui sont en train
de nous proposer des propositions sur
les 33% de postes non pourvu en
pharmacie donc on est en train
d'attendre ses propositions pour les
étudier et les mettre en oeuvre pour
l'année prochaine sur passlas et la
première année de même le comité de
suivi et la conférence des doyens sont
en train de donner leur rapport là
incessamment sous peu et je vous
rappelle qu'il y a aussi une mission qui
est en cours sur les paramédicaux tout
ça est en cours paramédical r1c méthode
enfin santé et pharmacie par les
conférences de pharmacie et nous
attendons d'avoir l'ensemble pour vous
donner sur les poids oral écris vous
savez les pourcentages sur les modalités
de contrôle sur les évolutions tout ça
est à l'ordre du jour
exactement nous avons identifié et pour
essayer de voir comment on peut un peu
mieux homogénéiser les différents points
qui sont remontés ce que je peux quand
même signaler c'est que les conclusions
qu'on a déjà eu du comité de suivière
ainsi vont déjà cette entrée que il y a
eu des évolutions par les établissements
qui ont pris en main déjà seul et avec
une amélioration de certains points
qu'il faut continuer à avoir avec un
cadrage probablement plus cohérent voilà
donc on l'a pas mais c'est en cours de
restitution des rapports de ces trois
types de rapports Pharma santé et
paramédicales voilà et ça fait partie
ces accompagnements par le tutorat aussi
de ces questions que les conférences de
doyen sont en train de de faire sur plus
particulièrement tout ce qui est privé
mais vous avez parlé de CPGE alors j'ai
pas le focus pour tout vous dire être
franche sur les CPGE d'économie j'ai
noté mais je pense que ma vision elle
est globale et je pense que le premier
cycle le poste bac doit être étudié avec
le ministère de l'Éducation nationale
dans les propositions d'orientation de
besoins de filière de développement des
filières par rapport au projet des
étudiants mais aussi par rapport aux
besoins de sortie des métiers et nous
allons faire ce travail pour orienter
nos étudiants dans l'ensemble des
premiers cycles donc il y a bien
évidemment les BTS les classes prépa
mais vous avez tout un tas de formations
qui se développent en double licence en
licence sélective en licence dans les
universités et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il faut regarder l'ensemble des
formations pour pouvoir voir qu'est-ce
qu'on peut offrir à nos étudiants et
comment on l'a dit tout à l'heure
valoriser l'université à travers aussi
les grandes écoles les filières
universitaires et l'ensemble des
filières
la recherche en mathématique je pense
c'est ça tu m'en veux indiquer
c'était ce point-là
donc sur monsieur le sénateur la
recherche en mathématiques en
particulier
sur de moins en moins de professeurs
voilà alors cette recherche en
mathématiques qui a la tribune
aujourd'hui qui est dans le aussi il y a
je vais compléter par le vivier de
professeur en mathématiques je vais
faire une réponse globale dans ce qui
concerne les mathématiques puisqu'il
faut
nous allons regarder très clairement et
nous retravaillons avec le ministère de
l'Éducation sur les maths mais plus
globalement sur les filières
scientifiques évidemment il y a un focus
particulier sur les maths mais sur les
filières scientifiques je pense que
aujourd'hui que ce soit les maths
l'informatique la physique les sciences
de l'ingénieur nous avons un petit peu
donc certes je pense qu'il faut être
très très vigilant à ne pas se focaliser
même si les maths est important et que
nous allons regarder à une seule filière
parce qu'il y a une tribune alors qu'il
y a d'autres disciplines et il faut que
nous nous avons la responsabilité d'un
peu levé le nez et de regarder un petit
peu l'ensemble des disciplines par
rapport à ce dont on a besoin et à ce
qu'il faut que l'on fournisse même si
nous sommes hyper fiers de nos médailles
et on fera en sorte que les maths parce
que c'est la socle continue mais les
médailles fixes ne font pas non plus
tourner toutes les machines donc je
pense qu'il faut prendre des positions
équilibrées même si c'est un point
important que j'ai toujours défendu et
que je continuerai à défendre donc ce
point sur les maths je voudrais dire
deux choses d'abord c'est une vision
globale qu'il nous faut et c'est ce
qu'on va avoir aussi bien au niveau
enseignement du secondaire qu'au niveau
attractivité dans le dans le supérieur
tout à l'heure papettia il a parlé des
jeunes filles je pense que c'est un
point important aussi et qu'il manque
cruellement parce que donne des biais
ensuite au développement beaucoup de
choses dans des filières dites de
sciences dures et c'est un peu un
ensemble à regarder Matt comprise bien
évidemment et sur les postes de
fournisseur en mathématiques je rappelle
l'autonomie des universités pour décider
de leur poste donc dans la tribu et
c'est normal parce que ce n'est pas
autant autonomie ne voulant pas dire
indépendance que je renvoie là-bas mais
ce sont des choix des universités de
mettre ou de ne pas mettre ou de
redéployer or l'analyse que l'on fait ce
n'est pas uniquement une diminution des
postes mais parfois des redéploiements
donc je pense qu'il y a un travail
commun à faire je vous signale vous le
savez tous il y a les assises des
mathématiques auxquelles je vais
personnellement participer avec mon
ancienne casquette j'ai d'ailleurs
participé à ses assises donc il y a une
vision globale que nous devons avoir
nous allons participer aux assises des
mathématiques nous allons travailler
avec les établissements en particulier
sur les mathématiques mais pas que je
pense qu'il y a l'ensemble des sciences
et l'impact sur les programmes du
secondaire avec le ministre de
l'éducation nationale pour regarder et
l'attractivité des jeunes filles sur ces
filières là je je pense que tous ces
points sont importants et vont être
gardés avec nos deux ministères
sur les CPJ oui c'est une c'est un
volant on en a parlé tout à l'heure
c'est un volant pour continuer à attirer
et mettre mais vous dites deux ans en
fait elles viennent certes les postes
viennent d'être pourvu là donc on a peu
de recul sur les profils et les postes
elles ont été lancées mais le
recrutement ont démarré à cette rentrée
là des premières CPJ et donc nous avons
peu de recul mais nous voyons que de
plus en plus les établissements font
appel à ces CPJ et dimensionne font des
profils de CPJ particulier pour
favoriser l'interdisciplinarité pour
favoriser de nouveaux profils
d'enseignants chercheurs pour ça voilà
étranger qui viennent du privé ou sur
des disciplines émergentes à risque dont
nous avons besoin et donc ils utilisent
ces outils comme un peu différemment des
postes classiques dont on a dans nos
établissements ce qui me semble une
bonne chose
sur les bourses collectivités
interviennent enfin Monsieur Brisson
donc sur les problématiques alors je
reprends
du guichet unique effectivement sur les
problématiques du guichet unique sur les
bourses donc oui c'est un vrai sujet
c'est une piste de regarder cela de
façon globale au niveau des bourses de
guichet unique ou de regarder ça
globalement ce que je voudrais rappeler
c'est que
lorsque nous avons augmenté les bourses
de 4%, nous avons embarqué toutes les
types de profils d'étudiants aussi bien
ce qui dépendait d'autres ministères
dans les formations que les formations
sanitaires et sociales qui dépendent des
régions et qui ont été embarqués dans
l'augmentation aussi des 4% et de l'aide
d'exceptionnelle de 100 euros de début
d'année nous avons eu cette vision
globale et c'est vraiment avec cette
vision globale que nous voulons
continuer à travailler sur les bourses
et donc évidemment avec les acteurs
importants de terrain donc sur j'ai noté
quelque part voilà je m'étais noté donc
c'est vrai que vous avez rappelé
l'expression de la présidente de région
d'Île de France qui je pense n'a pas
oublié son rôle d'ancienne ministre
aussi et connaît bien le sujet par
rapport à aider les étudiants ça me
donne l'occasion de vous dire que je
rencontrerai la semaine prochaine la
présidente de région de France avec qui
effectivement j'entends travailler de
manière très concrète sur ces sujets là
et donc avec l'ensemble le des régions
et je pense qu'il faut regarder ça de
façon
volontariste avec les acteurs qui le
sont d'ailleurs très présents en
accompagnant leur établissement
d'enseignement supérieur et ce
problèmeatique des bourses comme des
logements comme de l'accès au sport à la
culture comme de beaucoup d'autres
choses on a parlé de la restauration on
a vu les collectivités ou autre doit
être traitée avec les acteurs
territoriaux et c'est pour ça qu'on a
fait des dialogues territoriaux pour
adapter à chaque région en fait tout ce
qui est les différentes volets de la vie
étudiante et aussi traiter la
réalisation ou autre point pour la
réforme des bourses en considérant
l'ensemble et donc le guichet unique
peut-être un des points qui sera discuté
regarder de façon globale
sur le ah oui la LP r aussi avant c'est
ça la trajectoire LTR et l'inflation
alors sur l'énergie effectivement j'ai
bien parlé de mesures conjoncturelles
sur lequel nous allons accompagner les
établissements et prévoir une enveloppe
de compensation je pense que cette LP r
elle a été négociée avec un échéancier
et la premier point c'est déjà dans les
problématiques actuelles vous avez vu
que nous avons fait en sorte de
maintenir cette échéancier malgré les
difficultés actuelles et de ne pas je
dirais utiliser la LPR alors qu'elle
avait des mesures RH avoir par rapport
au point d'indice et à l'inflation donc
c'est vraiment notre feuille de route
moi c'est ma ligne rouge et c'est comme
ça qu'on l'appliquera ensuite il y a le
problème supplémentaire de l'inflation
je pense qu'il est urgent d'attendre de
regarder comment év cette inflation et
je propose et je voulais déjà dit je
suis venue je me suis engagée à revenir
vers vous vers le printemps avant l'été
pour faire un bilan de la LPM et de
revoir ses problématiques de la LPR dans
leur ensemble au moment du bilan pour
déjà voir leur application leur intérêt
leur conséquences et c'est ce que je
propose de revoir au niveau du bilan
sur
l'INP alors l'INSEP parle dans le lien
de tout à l'heure
là c'est lindsp donc sur l'inspect on
travaille actuellement professorat des
écoles parce que l'INSEP vous avez aussi
tout ce qui est collège master MEF sur
le secondaire là je vais je crois que
votre question portée sur les
professeurs des écoles et donc sur
l'attractivité je rappelle aussi que ces
réformes de sur les mastermaise je parle
pas d'inspeg ça date depuis 2010 2011 où
se succèdent les réformes sur les
masters MEF donc je avec des
allers-retours sur la place du concours
sur la place je pense que ça n'est pas
non plus
insignifiant par rapport aux problèmes
d'attractivité des étudiants et aussi de
lisibilité de la filière bien sûr il y a
les problèmes de salaire mais Monsieur
le Ministre papel Ndiaye a donné par la
suite des pistes et de revalorisation et
tout le travail qui est fait par le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale mais
sur l'attractivité des filières
effectivement aujourd'hui nous voulons
quelque chose de stable et de clair et
avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et je suis allée à la
Conférence des directeurs d'inspées la
semaine dernière pour commencer à
envisager un parcours à partir de la
première année de licence un parcours
propre fait en licence qui n'empêche pas
de garder des passerelles parce que un
étudiant à 18 ans lorsqu'il sort du bac
tous ne savent pas exactement qu'ils
veulent faire professeur des écoles mais
je pense qu'il peut y avoir des
vocations et aussi il faut aussi se
tester à ce nous à ce métier être sûr
que c'est bien ça que l'on veut faire
donc les passerelles étant dans les deux
sens et nous sommes en train de
travailler sur un parcours
qui va démarrer en licence avec une
continuité en master avec à la fois un
parcours qui va revenir sur des bases
disciplinaires solides mais aussi une
connaissance des métiers et ensuite une
implication dans le métier au niveau
master donc oui nous y travaillons avec
les INP avec l'Éducation nationale et
sur un système qui devrait apporter une
stabilité à la formation des professeurs
des écoles et une visibilité
oui
sur la cévêque
donc sur et je reviendrai sur la vie
étudiante monsieur Levi juste après
sur Madame borscho donc sur il y avait
les points fantins pardon sur madame la
sénatrice sur la cévêque pardon
Alexandra je me permets
je voulais revenir sur le point de la
cévêque sur dire que grâce à la cévêque
aujourd'hui mais vous l'avez dit que les
objectifs de la CV qui étaient clairs et
je pense que la cévêque c'est important
de le dire sur les volets sport sur les
volets santé sur les voter ouverture de
la culture diffusion a été quelque un
levier très très fort pour donner accès
aux étudiants par exemple à du sport
beaucoup d'établissements mettent une ou
deux séances de droit à tous les
étudiants quand on sait aujourd'hui la
problématique du sport sur la santé des
jeunes et le fait que les jeunes
n'acceptent pas au sport je pense que
ces accès au sport et à la culture pour
en faire des citoyens en bonne santé et
des citoyens éclairés c'est vraiment des
leviers importants dont c'est sans
emparés les établissements et le CROUS
sur les volets aussi diffusion etc donc
l'impact et on a les enquêtes est assez
fort sur ce qu'ils apportent aux
étudiants puisqu'ils reviennent aux
étudiants directement et je voudrais
rappeler qu'aujourd'hui cette de ces 90
comme c'est sur l'inflation c'est passé
actuellement à 95 parce que voilà c'est
mis sur l'inflation sont été mis à la
place de il y a quelques années à la
place de la
le régime étudiant sécurité sociale
c'est-à-dire que les étudiants payaient
200 euros environ j'ai plus le chiffre
205 je crois mais 217 merci beaucoup je
me j'ai 217 euros donc il payait 210 le
217 euros pour le régime étudiant de
Sécurité sociale et donc qui ont été
pris en charge et ne payent plus ces 217
euros et à la et ils ont quand même
évidemment le régime de sécurité sociale
dont il bénéficie à la place ils ont
payé 90 euros donc en fait ils ont gagné
sur leur pouvoir d'achat et c'est 90
euros leur permettent de gagner puisque
en plus il ne paye pas le sport au suave
ou la culture ou certaines actions de
santé dans lequel il y mais aussi
parfois des coûts et je vous rappelle
aussi que nous avons fait le passeport
pour les étudiants boursiers qui leur
permet avec le passeport d'aller faire
du sport sur 50 euros sur certaines
fédérations voire des des
structures privées de sport donc je
pense que le 90 euros de la CV avec tous
les services qui ont été mis au point
sur tous ces domaines et vraiment un
plus aux étudiants et qu'en fait ils ont
gagné sur le pouvoir d'achat par rapport
à l'économie sur les 219 euros de du
régime étudiant de Sécurité sociale et
moi c'est comme ça que je le vois par
rapport à l'évolution s'évêque versus
sécurité sociale dont il bénéficie aussi
encore aujourd'hui
sur je voudrais revenir monsieur le
sénateur Lévis sur le point important
mais je l'ai dit tout à l'heure sur je
crois que je voulais déjà dit sur là où
on en était mais sur le point je le
redis quand même
les gels de CROUS il y a eu les loyers
du CROUS qui ont été gelés je reviendrai
sur les charges et je rappelle qu'il y a
eu une augmentation de 3,5% des aPL qui
touche tout le monde donc aussi les
étudiants de classe moyenne pour les
accompagner aussi dans ces évolutions
sur les logements c'est ça que je
voulais ajouter par rapport aussi au
tarif de 3,3 euros dont on a parlé tout
à l'heure qui est quand même un tarif
social dont bénéficie tous les étudiants
qui est quand même très important mais
n'oublions pas cette augmentation aussi
des aPL de 3,5% pour tous les étudiants
sur Madame provoteau l'accès santé donc
on en a parlé tout à l'heure
est-ce que je
donc je pense que je vous ai répondu
voilà je refaisais le point sur le gel
des loyers par rapport au charges alors
je me tourne mais je crois que c'est
discrétion donc on me donne les charges
sont encadrées voilà donc c'est la
discrétion c'est les CROUS qui le vote
dans leur ca mais mais c'est les charges
sont encadrées et le 3% je suppose oui
ce que c'est un maximum c'est ça de 3%
c'est-à-dire que même si c'est voté dans
les ca c'est encadré avec un maximum de
3%. c'est la plupart ça a été votée
c'est très marginal voilà
j'espère ne rien avoir oublié non non je
crois que vous avez été très complète il
nous reste à vous remercier Madame
aministre de toujours le temps que vous
et le soin que vous prenez à répondre
précisément à chacune de nos questions
désolé la salle c'est un peu vidé mais
comme il y a un vote en même temps les
sénateurs sont partagés entre mes
comprenez bien entendu en tout cas merci
beaucoup et nous nous allons examiner
les auditions ne sont pas terminées je
crois pas complètement et bien sûr nous
aurons nous nous retrouverons en séance
dans quelques jours
merci à vous merci monsieur le président